the Joe Rogan experience when you watch
boxing or any combat sport really this
is guy that hit this level and you're
like oh during that [ __ ] super
champion zone yes and that's where
Crawford is why he needs to fight all
Spencer yes that's where low mashenka
was how was Earl Spencer live and not
injured I don't know because he's
Superman that video of him flipping a
Tequesta Ferrari and watching it fly
over him and he doesn't get crushed now
how what are the odds that home makes it
out of there without a scratch and thank
God because I had aficionado that work
of art needs to be preserved some days
it's fine little gay all about people
that are gay as [ __ ] but you did sound
yeah he's a beast man the way he shut
down Mikey Garcia it's too hard I'm
saying what Shawn Porter gave him the
what for Shawn Porter was that's what
you realize so important seven-time
world champion this week Todd gave him
the what for came the what full of that
flavor do you but that's what I say
sometimes I say things like there's ago
I'm gonna keep him busy
I'll give him the what for give him look
let's knew what would happen if Jamie
came at me right now sound like an actor
God asked me what would happen if Jamie
came out you meet him halfway
whoa Jamie's a big Jamie what happened
up Joe came at you come back with what I
got no really see that no watch now
watch this Jamie broke his butt bone out
here on one of them at home
yeah he was trying to figure out what
his injury is forever until Zach bitter
explained how he broke his butt bone and
Jamie's like that's exact same problem
I've been having
and it happened from him on those
[ __ ] the the hoverboard thing what oh
no fell on the concrete right out here
broke his butt yeah well maybe for sure
undiagnosed broken by most it's exactly
the same spot it's where he landed he
landed on his butt right Jamie Jamie yes
ask me if I ever killed a man did you
ever kill a man never stopped to look
brother
are you in The New Mickey Rourke movie
dude man how about me is a [ __ ]
action year was my name and a conveyed
my anaconda huh would you like a bag of
ropes now [ __ ] Anna Anna Anna and I
hate guys a girl know cuz they go he's
name is Anna and they go condé he ever
roll with him I was like like a boy
named Sue like B yeah one of my favorite
songs I mean a thing that he ever did
was go he went ahead and named me sue
that's a great [ __ ] one of the
greatest songs song that's a that's my
favorite Johnny Cash song Johnny Cash's
my daddy left home when I was three
didn't leave much from mommy it's this
old guitar an empty bottle of booze
[Applause]